Randy Moss NBC sports horse-racing
analyst he joins us now he'll be back on
the track Saturday night 8:30 Eastern on
NBCSN for the Breeders Cup Challenge
series live from Churchill Downs Randy
thanks for joining us where do you want
to start with what happened over the
weekend to Triple Crown winners in a
four year period three year period
really that's that's pretty phenomenal
isn't it we mean we wait 37 years for
American Pharoah 2015 and then 2018 I
mean here we go it's pretty cool is it a
good thing for the sport you know I
don't know that's a good question in the
the TV ratings for justify were a little
bit lower than they were for American
Pharoah or sits network television not
all TV ratings are kind of in a slow
decline the crowd I mean when justify
won yeah there was an there was an
outburst at Belmont Park and there was
you know the crowd noise was big as you
would expect wasn't quite the level that
we saw for American Pharoah which is
logical there were 37 years of pent-up
frustration for people at the track in
2015 it may not necessarily be the best
thing for thoroughbred racing but I
think as we pointed out on the telecast
historically these Triple Crowns tend to
happen in bunches and during that thirty
seven year period I think if you would
if you go back in a time capsule and you
could rerun all of those Derby Preakness
and Belmont so you probably would have
come up with four or five Triple Crown
winners that should have been that were
it not for just odd circumstances didn't
happen so I think we're kind of starting
to see that play out now
all right rapid-fire here was there a
horse held out of this race that that
could have one that helped justify
winning by not being in the race yes yes
his name was audible he was third in the
Kentucky Derby to be fair American
Pharoah handled him in the Derby but
audibles trained by Todd Pletcher who's
whose horses it
when the Derby typically are extremely
tough to beat in the Belmont Stakes but
audible is owned by the same ownership
group that has justified there was an
injury that was announced that audible
had suffered that a lot of people a lot
of other trainers on the backstretch
sort of snickered at that you know
they're convinced that the only reason
audible wasn't in the Belmont Stakes is
the fear that he would upset justify and
we just heard on the air that when star
farm people tell us on Saturday that lo
and behold audibles going right back
inside Fletcher's Park on Tuesday I know
the injury obviously wasn't much if it
was anything at all would he have won
the race the way to pace played out in
favor of justify it's hard to say that
audible would have won but it's entirely
possible final 30 seconds explain the
stud fee of the window of being a stud
for justifying how many years uh well
he'll be retired to stud almost
certainly at the end of this year just
like American Pharoah was and the money
involved Dan is just absolutely
staggering I mean look at American
Pharoah he retired after winning the
Breeders Cup Classic in 2015 his Stutz
he was listed as private it's known to
be $200,000 per breeding and he got 200
breedings in his first year in the
United States there's 40 million right
there been they sent him to Australia
because the Australian breeding season
just like the regular seasons local
southern hemisphere and Northern
Hemisphere are opposite so they put him
on a plane sent him to Australia and
bred him to a whole bunch of mayor's in
Australia so it's literally a cash
machine when you have horses of the
calibre of American Pharoah and justify
and justify has an even better pedigree
than American Pharoah at and he's a
better looking horse than American
Pharoah was so the money involved is
amazing Randy thank you
we'll be watching Saturday night with
the Breeders Cup from Churchill Downs
it's a Randy Moss NBC sports horse
racing analyst for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]